y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a esta emisión de los
observadores en france24 esta semana uno
de nuestros observadores en senegal
habló con sobrevivientes del terrible
incendio en una embarcación que se
dirigía hacia las islas canarias y que
dejó al menos 140 víctimas escucharán su
testimonio luego volveremos sobre las
elecciones presidenciales
estadounidenses que estuvieron marcadas
por las informaciones falsas
al menos 140 personas habrían muerto en
el incendio de esta embarcación frente a
san luis en senegal debía recorrer 1400
kilómetros para llegar hasta el
archipiélago español de islas canarias
que en estos últimos meses habéis una
renovación del interés de los viajeros
en san luís nuestro observador petit
team de ahí se reunió con algunos
sobrevivientes de la tragedia y un motor
de la embarcación se averió y cuando
soltó chispas se incendiaron unas
botellas de reserva de gasolina y unas
bombonas de gas y ahí fue el sálvese
quien pueda
en su equipo el pánico hizo que algunos
se lanzarán directamente al mar sin
tomar todas las precauciones y las
medidas necesarias para poder salvarse
para san luís hubo muchos muertos el
vídeo de los pescadores que salvaron
algunas personas y que se volvió viral
puede dar una idea del sufrimiento que
estos jóvenes vivieron
estos últimos días nos hemos dado cuenta
de que muchos otros barcos zarparon
algunos encallaron en las playas de san
luís y otros en las costas de dakar
entre las personas a bordo hay
pescadores víctimas de la escasez del
pescado pero no solamente en un país con
48% desempleados muchos quieren huir
y cada vez hay más candidatos a la
inmigración clandestina porque el
fenómeno es general
todos los jóvenes están desesperados y
todos son obreros y todos tienen alguna
profesión
algunos son carpinteros plomeros
mecánicos albañiles y no han renunciado
a la idea de irse porque dijeron que las
condiciones siempre serían las mismas
cuando decimos barça o barça barça es
barcelona barça que es la muerte o el
infierno ellos dicen que el infierno
está aquí
después de una campaña para la elección
presidencial estadounidense marcada por
un diluvio de informaciones falsas los
periodistas especialistas en
verificación en eeuu se sorprendieron de
no ver más que algunos casos aislados de
noticias falsas el día de la votación
verán algunas noticias falsas detectadas
por la reacción de los observadores las
cuales también podrán encontrar en
nuestra página web primero esta foto
donde se ve un seguidor de donaldson
sosteniendo una bandera según unos
internautas varias personas habrían
bloqueado el acceso a los puestos de
votación en clips de nueva jersey unos
medios estadounidenses investigaron y
pudieron identificar la foto fue tomada
dos días antes de la elección en primero
de noviembre
delante de la alcaldía de clifton y el
hombre no estaba para nada bloqueando un
puesto de votación sino simplemente
pasaba a delante de un buzón de los
correos donde podía depositar su
papeleta
la escena no duró más que unos segundos
no se trataba para nada de un bloqueo de
los puestos de votación como algunos
quisieron hacer creer esta temática de
bloqueo de los puestos de votación
también aparece entre los seguidores del
presidente de donald trump este vídeo
por ejemplo pretende mostrar que unos
manifestantes demócratas bloquean unos
puestos de votación e intimida a los
electores en carolina del norte en
realidad este vídeo fue grabado de 31 de
octubre cuatro días antes de la elección
muestra un agrupamiento organizar el
rafam en carolina del norte para incitar
a los estadounidenses a salir a votar el
día de la elección
la policía había dispersado la
manifestación porque estaba bloqueando
una calle y no había sido autorizada
pero en todo caso estos manifestantes no
bloquearon un puesto de votación el día
de la elección finalmente una teoría de
conspiración bastante sorprendente
volvió a surgir la noche de la elección
unos internautas compartieron fotos como
está afirmando que mostraba
pilas de ladrillos depositados en el
andén en la ciudad de chicago para ellos
no cabía duda esos ladrillos probarían
que ya se habían previsto disturbios
después de la elección y que estas
serían las municiones preparadas para
los futuros agitadores
el restaurante delante del cual fueron
depositados esos ladrillos rápidamente
lo desestimó es un ladrillo fueron
puestos a disposición de un restaurante
vecino que estaba construyendo una
terraza varios días antes de la votación
de hecho esos ladrillos desaparecieron
del andén el día 3 de noviembre entonces
no tienen nada que ver con los
disturbios planeados las falsas
informaciones fueron poco frecuentes el
día de la votación pero hasta qué punto
la desinformación marco la campaña
estadounidense se lo preguntamos a
daniel funk y periodista para el medio
de verificación estadounidense
politifact
en efecto hubo muchas informaciones
falsas y desinformación sobre esta
elección la campaña de trump insiste
sobre el hecho de que el voto por
correspondencia y el voto en general no
es tan seguro como los estadounidenses
creen hay relativamente pocos incidentes
o fraudes electorales cada año en eeuu y
el voto por correspondencia está
asegurado en todos los estados del país
el presidente de trump realmente no ha
tratado de defender su balance sobre la
lucha contra la pandemia en varias
ocasiones durante el año el presidente
donald trump incluso trató de minimizar
la gravedad de la pandemia de
coronavirus trump dijo que estamos
saliendo el coronavirus que ya casi se
acaba en realidad la cantidad de casos y
de muertos ha estado aumentando desde
mediados de septiembre con un pico en el
mes de octubre
no es un secreto donald trump es un
proveedor histórico de mentiras
nosotros hemos verificado sus
declaraciones cientos de veces desde que
es presidente al ver sus resultados
determinamos que 36 por ciento de esas
declaraciones eran falsas 16 por ciento
de ellas de manera evidente se trata
entonces de una gran proporción de
declaraciones falsas provenientes de un
presidente en cuanto a joe biden 17 por
ciento de las declaraciones que
verificamos eran falsas verificamos los
hechos de todas las campañas todos los
días eso no se detendrá el día de la
elección ha sido un año excepcional por
muchas razones las informaciones falsas
y la desinformación seguirán circulando
después nos mantendremos atentos a las
declaraciones falsas en torno a esta
elección
esto fue todos los observadores de esta
semana todos nuestros contactos aparecen
en pantalla y si quieren enviarnos sus
fotos y vídeos de aficionado no lo duden
no dude en contactarnos para mostrarnos
lo que ocurre cerca de ustedes hasta
pronto